you don't want some very revealing
things like you discuss your honeymoon
you discuss intimate details of your
honeymoon
well I read that part several times
everything alone in the bathroom yes I
have my beautiful wife Robyn and I were
celebrated our 20th anniversary just
recently and admittedly a cheap applause
line oh yeah wonderful what we were we
were in in Europe for a honeymoon and
one of the parts of the trip was to go
from Switzerland to Italy and instead of
going over the Alps they said take the
train and you were gonna be in a car
imagine a flatbed train where three cars
bumper-to-bumper are on it going through
the Train like a ferry you drive your
car up drive your car onto a train and
then it takes you that nice trip we were
in the middle there was a van full of
kids in front of us and a two couples
from Italy and back of us and the the
travel agent said by the way the third
tunnel is 50 minutes long it's tradition
for honeymooners to take advantage of
that time
I said capisce I said we're doing this
Wow okay my wife chagrin yeah you know
the had yet talked her into it right I
said are you ready to to you know to use
up seven calories yeah because yeah I
don't know what to do with the extra
forty seven minutes after the fifty
minutes lets you know you're
honeymooners you're gonna be in the dark
it's kind of exciting yeah it's gonna be
a little bit of a rocking you know the
rocking motion that it was like being in
a ton that this tunnel was completely
dark it was an absence of light you
couldn't see your hand in front of your
face night and the wind was rushing and
it was exciting right on this train and
so we went through one tunnel and I said
that's one we got to get to the third
tunnel and by the time the third tunnel
my wife is saying just just get it over
with
so we go in we're in the dark we got 50
minutes and I she's reclining her seat
now this is a tiny little car that yeah
they make small cars over there yeah and
we're in it's a stick shift ya know I
take off my pants and I take off my
underwear oh man
and I'm gonna make my way over to her
side of the Oh this is something a very
important lesson the next time you all
do this before transferring from one
seat to another and and crossing over
the panel with a stick shift make sure
you keep your trousers on for that walk
for that part yeah after that take them
off after that for the stick shift yeah
yeah
but I got past that yeah so reclining
we're going I can't see anything and and
we're enjoying our lovemaking if you
don't want to call it that yes yes I
would call it that Shakespeare would say
you bear beast with two backs and be
sure to backs
you know let's elevate our language the
horizontal mambo exactly we were we
worked and my wife I said and you know
you're like this and you're trying and
she's like would you just just come just
go and all of a sudden within a short
period of time I start seeing the
features of my beautiful life space and
I'm thinking my eyes are getting
acclimated to this yeah yeah you're
ahead of me aren't you
within seconds Wham
we're out in broad daylight well I'm
like now what happened to the fifty
meters that's what I said
you're the Italian you're the for cup of
the two couples behind I'm like this I
can almost see you there looking at her
yeah and and the Italian men of course
[Laughter]
what about the children oh god they're
turning around and their grandmothers
like no no no no yeah she gives me a
look like you know this guy's clearly
playing a prank on you
yes yes right and my gorgeous wife says
to me three those three words you always
want to hear get off
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you